hallo leute willkommen zu einer neuen
episode unserer super easy german reihe
in welcher wir euch jede woche die
wichtigsten deutschen werben beibringen
diese woche geht es um das verb wissen
wir zeigen euch wie ihr es konjugieren
könnt und in verschiedenen zeitformen
verwenden könnt los gehts präsenz ich
weiß du weißt er sie es weiß
wir wissen ihr wisst sie wissen
marina du siehst gut aus ja ich weiß
alina ich weiß dann geheimnis jeder weiß
dass janosch weiß dass er nichts weiß
eigentlich nicht ich weiß dass ich nicht
alles weiß
weißt du wie ich heiße klar du bist
alina wir wissen was euch beim
deutschlernen hilft
und ihr wisst was ihr tun müsst
kriterium
ich wusste du wusstest er sie es wusste
wir wussten ihr wusstet sie wussten
alina ich schaffe es nicht
ich wusste es wusstet ihr dass es
weltweit 90 bis 105 millionen deutsche
muttersprachler gibt janosch wusste was
ihm fehlte
ein cappuccino früher wussten die leute
wie man schöne häuser baut perfekt ich
habe gewusst
du hast gewusst er sie es hat gewusst
wir haben gewusst ihr habt gewusst
sie haben gewusst alina hast du gewusst
dass die erde flach ist
nein das habe ich noch nicht gewusst
ihr habt bestimmt noch nicht gewusst
dass piehler dichter und schriftsteller
ist genau
janosch hat den namen der pflanze nicht
gewusst aber die app hat ihm geholfen
kultur ich werde wissen
du wirst wissen sie es wird wissen wir
werden wissen
ihr werdet wissen sie werden wissen
kari fährt fahrrad ohne zu gucken
sie wird schon wissen was sie tut wir
werden nie wissen warum wir existieren
janus der makler hat angerufen morgens
früh werden wir schon wissen ob wir die
neue wohnung bekommen
ich kann es kaum abwarten alle deutschen
werben haben zwei formen des konjunktiv
2 wir stellen euch heute beide vor mal
benutzt man die eine mal benutzt man die
andere
das ist abhängig vom kontext je nachdem
was gerade natürlicher klingt wird
benutzt dafür gibt es keine bestimmte
regeln konjunktiv 2 ich wüsste du
wüsstest er sie es wusste wir wüssten
ihr wüsstet sie wüssten
ich wusste keine antwort auf die frage
ich wüsste keinen grund dafür
ich wüsste nicht warum ich das tun
sollte
ich würde wissen
du würdest wissen er sie es würde wissen
wir würden wissen
ihr würdet wissen sie würden listen
janusz würde gerne wissen wie das
funktioniert
ich würde gerne wissen was der spaß
kostet alina ich würde gerne wissen
warum du so schlecht gelaunt bist sage
ich aber nicht das war unsere episode zu
dem verb wissen wenn ihr jetzt eure
deutsch noch weiter verbessern möchtet
dann empfehlen wir euch unsere app sieht
lang ausprobieren
dort haben wir unter anderem viele
verschiedene geschichten für euch
vorbereitet mit denen ihr euer deutsch
schritt für schritt verbessern könnt ihr
euch die regeln der deutschen grammatik
beibringen viel spaß dabei und bis zur
nächsten woche
[Musik]